hallo mein name ist luca bei der lieben
freunde ich bin krank habe 39 grad
fieber und ernähre mich den ganzen tag
über nur von wasser und buchstabensuppe
von daher habe ich mir gedacht schauen
wir uns heute mal gemeinsam ein video
von kuchen an und das
das sieht 11 aus einfach wie ein 1 4
sich aber es ist einfach ein viel sich
mit so orio creme drin wir schauen uns
hier heute mal einige videos an zum
thema kuchen die sowie realistische
objekte aussehen zum beispiel dass wir
vorne das wird eine wassermelone
ey
wie viel zeit verbringen einige leute
der küche das ist ja jetzt packt wieder
sogar noch sonne sondern wie grass sieht
denn das aus ich kann mir nicht mal
vernünftig kellogg's machen ihrem
heutigen video wird wie es
wahrscheinlich gerade schon gehört haben
nicht wie ihr gehört habt sondern wie
ist ja meine gesundheit glaube ich auch
annehmen können wir heute nicht so viel
geschnitten dass das ist krass guck mal
die meinen dass sogar an mit so essbarer
farbe wahrscheinlich also wird es nicht
erst mal wäre blöd wenn wir drin ist den
kuchen 8 grüne neune so sieht später
hier der kuchen auch wenn das ein
supermarkt liegen würde das wäre einfach
eins zu eins ich würde es einfach
niemals melone hier ist einfach sondern
sonne und ich mache mir da wenigstens
schokolade wäre dann könnte man einfach
noch so mit der schokolade dass ihnen
wie meine form machen aber mit einem
kuchen muss ja alles eins machen komme
hier liegen bananen rum er schneidet die
auf dass das ist ja ganz normale ballade
das ist ein kuchen ich finde jetzt
zeigen die zeigen die das video zeigt
der sprachenlernen buchstabensuppe wir
zeigen dir wie die das gemacht haben
ich glaube dass es dann so ein schaum
kuchen oder irgendwie so heißt das er
ist relativ stabil für so was also der
plot stets nicht ein oder so aber guck
mal mit was für einer sorgfalt die daran
gehen und die malen hey das ist ja irre
das hier ist der nächste kuchen und es
sieht einfach aus wie sonne wie so eine
glitschige frucht oder irgendwie sowas
oder wie ein apfel oder so aber man
sieht schon dass es in so einem die
lebkuchen oder so wenn er denn hinter
der stiftung das tier auf dem salat
dingsbums was ist einfach ein kuchen
guckt euch das an
wenn das im supermarkt zu liegen würde
ich würde das mitnehmen da will ich den
salat machen dann würde ich quasi haben
kuchen essen hier sehen wir eine chips
packung und zwar dough riedos und das
ist doch kein kuchen
schaut euch das mal kunststoff aber
schaut euch mal auch hier die die
lichtreflexion an
ok
ich fresse den ganzen tag
starben suppe ich habe so einen appetit
auf kuchen gerade das ganze ist übrigens
nicht gesponsert von maggi oder keine
ahnung was hier um gottes willen ich
kann die buchstabensuppe wirklich nie
mehr sehen aber auch noch mal ein dickes
sorry dass auch im heutigen video nicht
so viel geschnitten ist von mir aber ich
lieg den ganzen tag im bett
ich dachte mir bevor ich gar nichts
laden gehen wir gemeinsam auf kuchen von
der clique ich mal weiter auf play luc
vincent die base case that look like any
thing but can
das ist nicht wahr warte
war wartet moment ich muss noch einmal
kurz die zum anfang spielen
[Musik]
das passiert das ist sieht doch aus wie
eine dose also wirklich diese
lichtreflektionen und so das ist ja
unfassbar kuppel schneidet das einfach
durch und das ist unser system kommt es
ist komplett kuchen ein
ey
der was der teller und der löffel auch
das ist ein stück ich komm nicht klar
ich komme nicht mehr guckt euch das an
das und alles suchen was sie da sehen
das ist eine gut schrieb beck das hier
ist ein okay das würden wir auch
erkennen glaube ich das iphone aber auch
hier die cartier box ja okay dann das
finde ich kann man erkennen mit der
erdbeere aber auch da allein das hier so
extra einkerbungen sind das ist ja nicht
so wie also für die kerle das ist ja
dass das
ich komme gerade gar nicht klar
ich komme gar nicht klar das ist was was
ich auch gar den ganzen tag esse ich es
tagtäglich gerade circa 17.000 zitronen
also das ist auf jeden fall der
zitronenkuchen das sieht auch extrem
krass aus dass jetzt noch mal der eier
kartonagen kuchen vom gerade also in dem
er von ihm sehen wollt also dieser
theorie dass anscheinend auch von ihm
schaut auf jeden fall mal blut wünschen
kino kino vorbei bei instagram erstes
jahr
das ist ja irre
the same schaut euch das mal anders das
fand ich krass mit dem löffel halt auch
vorhin also da hätte ich halt wirklich
gedacht okay der kuchen steht zumindest
auch so nach untertasse uns und mit dem
löffel daneben gehalt von wegen
das ist ne
ein
ich
buchstaben so papier sehen wir ein stück
fleisch das sogar so ein bisschen runter
geht wie so ein stück fleisch wenn man
da schneidet eben
ich bin ich bin beeindruckt ich bin
wirklich beeindruckt von leuten die so
etwas hinkriegen
ich meine ich selbst koche auch sehr
gerne okay das ist jetzt natürlich
backen und nicht kochen aber er schaut
euch das an das sieht aus wie so jussi
früchte aber es ist einfach kuchen ich
bin so begeistert von solchen leuten ich
selbst koche sehr sehr sehr sehr gerne
da habe ich richtig das nie so toll an
wisst ihr was mein so es gibt ja voll
viele influenza und blogger und keine
ahnung was sie dann ihr frühstück machen
und dann legen die bären in seiner
perfekten reihenfolge hin und so ich
meine ich es so was auch sehr gern und
mache mir sowas auch selbst sehr gerne
allerdings mache ich das halt nie so
krass ist ihr so krass platzieren und so
weiter und so fort ich habe keine ahnung
allerdings was dass sie jetzt auch
gerade werden soll also ich hab wirklich
bisher absolut gar keine ahnung
was tut sie da
also bisher sieht es nicht so gut aus
aber vielleicht ist es halt die
grundlage also ich finds halt krass klar
das sind leute die machen das beruflich
und so weiter und so fort ist es
wahrscheinlich einholen sieht man jetzt
auch aber
ihre auch hier schaut euch das an hey
ich komme gar nicht klar es tut mir leid
aber ich bin ein mensch der sehr sehr
sehr sehr einfach beeindrucken kann
somit katze in london habe ich mich zum
beispiel eine stunde angesetzt haben
einfach schwerer angeguckt und fand es
bemerkenswert
ja ich weiß ich bin opfer früher als
meine ganzen omas und opas noch gelebt
haben war es halt so dass die auch
richtig viel kuchen gebacken haben und
dann waren bei denen und keiner wusste
so wirklich was man damit anfangen soll
aber das finde ich krass vermutlich
machen das ganze so riesigen events und
so weiter und so fort also jetzt nicht
so im sinne von lass es doch kein kuchen
dass das ist doch
ihr wollt ihr mich fragt ich finds halt
bemerken sein was sie dann auch für
techniken verfolgen sage ich mal nur um
diesen kuchen halt so hinzukriegen wie
der kunde das wünscht oder wie die
selbst wenn die sicherheit von dem her
ich mache jetzt ein kuchen so aussehen
wie ein airport oder irgendwie sowas sie
dann alles in angriff nehmen um das halt
wirklich so hinzukriegen finde ich halt
extrem krass
heilker das ist doch
ist doch irre klar wir gucken uns hier
ein video an mit dem kugl okay das hat
mir vorhin schon und wir wissen dass das
alles kuchen sind aber dennoch denke ich
mir im ersten moment immer wenn ich
leuten kuchen als er denkt das kann doch
niemals ein kuchen sein
das ist so crazy guckt euch das an was
sie dafür techniken verfolgen die die
macht etwas mit einer schere extra das
überfällige
ich habe ganz riesigen
ganz ganz riesigen respekt für euch
so sorry mir ging es gerade bisschen
schwindlig um herrn beim schädel hier
haben wir als nächsten kuchen wieder ein
iphone also es sieht so crazy echt aus
ist es unfassbar dass sie soll eine
drachenfrucht sein glaube ich also sie
zumindest von außen aus dass hier wieder
noch rund das so sagt er vorher aus
glaube ich okay ach das ist jetzt eine
time lab sowie die den hund so
hingekriegt haben ein paar sekunden
später
schaut euch mal nur diesen bereich an
den ich euch hier gerade herangezoomt
habe
das ist doch eh schon das überschreitet
ja schon die die die buchstabensuppe
hier haben wir einfach eine kamera die
ein kuchen ist und hier seht ihr jetzt
nicht okay ihr seht jetzt wird das
gemacht dass ich glaube das ist wirklich
dieser schaum kuchen oder so korrigiert
mich gern wenn ich falsch liege aber so
machen die das auf jeden fall also
nehmen wir verschiedene schneiden da
verschiedene teile einfach raus packten
die zusammen und dann halt ich habe
converse das doch irre
das ist so allein mit den verschiedenen
farben so richtig hier so ausgefranst
und so wie schnürsenkel kann es
wahrscheinlich auch noch mit essen so
wie es aussieht das hier ist einfach
sonne gebäck tüte ich meine schaut euch
das an
das sind einfach donuts und alles
mögliche und hier ist auch so eine tüte
dargestellt aber es ist einfach alles
ein kuchen
und ich
ich kann
einfachen billardkugeln als wochen habe
ich glaube nur die hier die anderen
waren normale kugeln die skateboard
daisy ja danke das habe ich auch schon
im titel entnehmen können wenn das und
kuchen ist ein kommen ja gar nicht klar
aber das hier ist ja so heftig also die
kuchen die man hier gerade sitzung vom
markt perkins gemacht worden küche
differenz steht hier das sieht ja das
ist ja unfassbar was sich hier auch hier
mit dem mit dem billardkugeln
das ist ja
ich bin so begeistert von von manchen
menschen auf dieser welt was die können
und dann gibt es halt mich
richtig ich kann echt nichts an der
stelle wird das heutige video allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch meine reaktion hierauf kuchen die
aussehen die echte objekte gefallen hat
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da schnappe mir gerne in die
kommentare ob ihr gerade gesundheit oder
auch krank wir hören können bin ich
topfit spaß beiseite freunde mir geht es
gerade wirklich nicht so gut ich habe
die ganze zeit das gefühl dass ich
kotzen muss ich habe kopfschmerzen ich
habe husten und ich habe immer noch ein
bisschen fieber leider das sieht jetzt
auch schon seit mehreren tagen deswegen
war das video gestern und auch das
heutige wie die jetzt nicht so krass
geschnitten ich meine gestern habe ich
fast gar nicht geschnitten heute habe
ich mich wieder so ein bisschen dran
versucht aber mein kopf dröhnt einfach
ich hoffe dass es ab morgen oder
spätestens ab übermorgen normale videos
weitergeben kann
bis dahin wünsche ich euch schlagen
suppe
[Musik]
ein